[Music]  knock it off  todd i think amber's been pretty clear  about how she feels i'm nothing like my  dad  i want to be just like you  i fought to keep this planet safe  your power's got to be due any day now  morning i'm scared dad what if i can't  do this  follow me go down  land i said land stop  get up i'm actually getting used to this  a little that's not good  need to be better after everything he's  done how can i live up to all that  you need to decide what kind of hero you  want to be  that was you in the blue and the yellow  why don't you meet the team after school  may we count on you in the future yeah  i think so and bored of this  [Music]  son we need to talk  what i'm about to tell you will change  everything  dad  i wasn't ready before now i am  you being a superhero is the coolest  thing that's ever happened to me now  take me flying or i'm gonna tell  everyone  you're invincible sorry not sorry  you